a long snapper of USC joining us here on
the show how are you Jake are you I just
want to say that was awesome that was
what was it like for you Jake oh it was
it was awesome I mean a long time wait
for it and it just was a very special
special moment I mean it's even when I
think about it today and just you know
it's like wow hey I contributed to a
point yeah I contributed to the to it to
a USC football game was out there on a
snap and it just it's it's it's
incredible for me to think about and say
and just was a very special moment for
for all sports so when did you first get
walk me through how you first got it
hooked up with Pete Carroll and USC Jake
how old I grew up a huge Trojan sin and
I mean how could you not and when you
live in LA you know in the 2000 and so
basically when I was 12 and in 2009 my
face cancer and always my whole lives
and so I was my cancer come back this
last time and the doctor says got to
lose my remaining eye that there was
really no more treatment options and so
that story through multiple avenues
somehow reached coach Carroll a mess he
and basically he invited me up for a
practice and III only thought I was
gonna be a practice I didn't think is
gonna be much but I mean even even at 12
years of practice I mean I was just the
most awesome experience but sure enough
he brought me to you know pre pre
practice meetings and then you know
obviously went from there from you know
going to the team Otero's and traveling
and you know locker rooms before after
games on the field that you know just
every part of being a member of the team
and you can imagine you know I I
experienced and that was just an awesome
awesome experience you know again just a
situation I'm facing you know becoming
blind and to have coach Carroll in the
Trojans along with me and fighting
through that just and just made all the
difference in the world so that's that's
really how my USC connection started and
you know obviously officially join the
family and then you know eight years
later Here I am snapping in the game
well before we get to that so you still
have a relationship with Coach Carroll
right Pete's pizza pad you two Super
Bowls plural
correct yeah no he uh he's just such a
gracious guy I mean he didn't have to
take me under his wing here I see and
then you know obviously when he left to
Seattle he didn't you didn't have to you
know bring me up there but yeah I've
been to plenty plenty games up there
been you know getting with the team and
you know went so tells and you know
close with a couple guys up there and
you have been to both Super Bowls one
was a lot better than the other yeah
sure sure but uh no you just an awesome
guy's been my mentor you know we talked
on the phone a lot the guy that we just
get along you know we have both similar
mindsets of just dominating lice and
winning forever and you know not letting
anything stop you so I mean it's just
it's really been an awesome relationship
dominating life winning forever Jake I
love that you should make a t-shirt
that's awesome that's great I mean
that's a great it's a great mantra it's
a great way to live life Jake and and
then you know so how did you get hooked
up with Clay Hilton I mean just because
you around the program and obviously
Clay's with the program how did you get
hooked up to be part of this team with
the uniform and everything well so in
high school I didn't play my freshman
sophomore year I went to Lawrence
Lutheran you know we plan to turn into
Trinity League so you know you're the
face you know Marte and Bosco and
certified every year so I mean there's
there's some pretty tough competition
obviously and I didn't think there
really was a place for me out on the
football field and I didn't play my
freshman sophomore year well I kind of
grew tired of sitting on the sidelines
and just watching I miss really miss
being out there so I want to find a way
back on the field and I came across a
long striving position and basically the
whole summer going into my junior year
practice every day
to try to you know get to honing the
skills of long snapping and sure enough
my when we came in for fall camp my
junior year they lined up all the long
snappers and I was the best one so I
earned a starting spot in varsity and
played for two years and I always wanted
to go to SC so I made sure I had the
grades and once I was accepted you know
Pat Haden at the time along with Coach
shark both said you know Jake since are
going to be here you know you know I
don't want to play football and that was
just you know like oh my goodness I I
you know I love playing football just
and I knew it can be around the program
while
I just never knew I was me actually part
of it as a player so that really really
was something special and ever since has
been working hard at practice on the
earthen Plains on Jake Olson USC long
snapper after snapping an extra point in
a game and a win 49:31 over Western
Michigan joining me here on the show
all right so walk me through this
weekend when did you first realize that
this could actually happen that you
could get in this game against Western
Michigan Jake about Thursday
coach Helton came up to me and said you
know it's moving towards uh the
likelihood that you're gonna snap in
this game just you know mentally prepare
yourself and you know I know you're
ready you've earned this so just you
know just make sure you you feel good
and you mentally prepare yourself and
then Friday confirmed it like yeah we're
gonna get you in to stay ready and so it
definitely was a couple nervous nervous
nights just you know again yeah I I
trusted in my stomach trust in my
technique you know it was something that
I've done thousands of times it's just I
knew this moment was gonna be bigger
bigger than sports just because you know
I had a chance to really inspire
thousands and obviously just Trojan
nation and was waiting for this moment
and as was I and it just was kind of
emotional as well so you know it's a
little anxiety but again once I was
running out there you know I really just
was focused on the snap but afterwards I
mean it was just really emotional very
very excited I mean I I've never been
more happy just it is it just was again
it's just something I had to say to
myself because just like oh my goodness
I just I just snapped as a su Trojan in
a game like that's just that just for
someone who's grown up as a fan and you
know adored teens for you know 20 years
of my life it just to be out there as
one of those just crazy well I mean just
I've watched the moment over and over
and over again Jake as has by the way I
think you're under estimating the number
of people even spired it's not in
thousands it's in it's in the millions
it really is and I've watched the moment
over and over again and and I couldn't
help but notice the umpire Mike Stevens
was the name of the umpire come up to
you and say something to you and I guess
tapped me on the shoulder can you walk
me through what what the umpire the
official out there was doing with
so I mean officials obviously that they
spent over the ball and whistle you know
into so that you know always seen it's a
long time bringing just pretty common
for them to just stand there and then
whistle it live and then back up but he
pretty much just again did did it's most
officials did in high school just
basically you know say okay you know
you're gonna grab the ball now like and
then he kind of tapped me like let's get
it and then he just reminded you know
the defense like stay off the snapper
and then then backed up so you you know
but my sister actually was walking kind
of I by the locker room after the game
and officials were walking out the
tunnel and he overheard them saying like
I can't help but cry and when he snapped
the ball no you know it was cool just
even see the officials impacted just in
the game there yeah I mean I'm in the
video that we've been showing to our
audience Jake
I guess that is that your dad that that
that that was with you right afterwards
and your family right in the tunnel
coming out of the locker my dad my
sister what was that moment for you like
I've never seen my dad more happy
honestly but it was awesome you know you
know I mentioned this in the ESPN
interview afterwards but it's just you
know I my parents went through a lot you
know as any parent who's had a baby with
cancer knows you know for 12 years they
saw their their baby boy battled cancer
and obviously go blind and that you know
as much pain and then her I I endured
that you know they endure just the same
amount and just you know and maybe even
worse because it just you see someone
always who's your child someone you love
that much to go through that pain you
know you can't really do anything but be
there for them and so just to know that
I was able to go out there and say you
know yeah mom and dad like I did go
through through cancer I went blind but
this isn't stopping me in life you know
please don't worry about me I can live a
great life and thrive and let's make
them make them proud and that happy and
you know hopefully take away some of
that that pain of watching their son
hurt so I mean that was really what was
going through my mind with them it's
just making them proud and happy and
just again just knowing know making them
know that there's their boy gonna be
okay despite you know everything that
happened and I can't forget Jake the
family member with four legs come on now
Quebec was there too you're there
because that
because that guy mono I'm waiting for
him to break out of Locker and run on a
few like travelers or you're saying yeah
we know you come running a walker ready
to get in time you know he he waits in
there for me and really it's a bracings
value so he wants to find me so I always
take is a little jailbreak and he'd be
running out how long you been with
Quebec and in he with you I've come back
to then my guide dog for over six years
and he's awesome and he's he's my right
or I guess he's on my left when we buddy
guys means my left hand man mmm-hmm but
he's an awesome dog you mean he loves me
and it's just he's awesome I guess
they're gonna ask you Jake what's next
what he got what do you got plans what
do you want to do next well I mean
hopefully this time one time you know
experience I want to want to keep
working and you know as I coached Alton
as I told him you know when I when I
first met him just you know when II
became coach was you know just put me in
when he feel I'm ready and I've earned
it and he obviously felt that I had and
so you know the more stamps I get in
practice and you know the more more
gaining stance more confidence you know
obviously we have is just a unit and he
has to me and so I just want to be able
to play more games my last two seasons
here and then just make the most of it
and obviously earning earning a great
business degree from from a great
university and you know see we see where
life takes me I wanted to continue
inspire others and you know I love
sports don't really want to leave the
sports world so we'll see
what about playing golf I heard you talk
about it with Dan Patrick earlier today
I heard you got a good stick what about
what about doing that professionally any
any plans dreams on that front no I I
mean I I love golf and it's something
that I really want to continue to work
out you know I want to definitely win a
cup of wine golf championships and again
it get to a point where they qualify for
Hilla PGA tournaments I think that would
be something very special if you saw me
walking around a PGA tournament okay
swim with Mike let's talk about this
before I let you go it raises money over
19 million dollars over the last 40
years
scholarships toward physically
challenged athletes all over the country
what does this program mean to you Jake
it's awesome
it's a great great great organization
you know obviously given me hope and a
chance to come to a great University and
hundreds and thousands of other kids as
well that you know that have gone
through injuries that have either and
that have ended their athletic careers
or you know hindered it in a way and you
know to give them just that hope to
carry on and continue pursuing dreams
despite whatever challenge they now face
given their injury and it's just it's
just an awesome organization you know I
encourage everyone to check it out and
donate it again and you know my story
and there's there's countless of other
stories out there that just del amaze
you and just you know knowing these kids
again are going to great universities
and making lives out of situations that
are very less than a deal
swim with Mike dot-org is how you can
find out more and take part in it and
drop a name Jake who did you hear from
over the last 48 hours
big tweets Tony Dungy tweet at me Mike
Mike Trout tweeted at me
we got a lot of different shows
obviously you know they've been on you
know Rich Eisen Howard's we know it's
all good Jake I mean look let me tell
you what you what you did and what
you've done is is beyond inspirational
and awesome you know I I got emotional
watching it I'm getting emotional now
just talking you about it and
congratulations and I look forward to
seeing even greater moments from you I
will do that you got it right on you got
it
at Jake Olson OLS and 61 the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to